hé tout le monde, c'est un artisan de la
paix, j'ai fait cette bande-annonce explicite
pour vous, ça va vous époustoufler
,
les enfants, et c'est comme ça que j'ai vaincu
les méchants les plus dangereux du monde avec
seulement mes deux poings,
mon aigle du désert
et deux lance-roquettes, mangez la paix,
[ __ ],
toutes les questions ont  tu as rencontré
Wonder Woman, elle a passé une fête entière si en moi de l'autre côté de la pièce mec malade mec j'ai dit effin d'
accord
pacificateur j'hésitais à
t'amener dans cette équipe
mais en ce moment le monde a besoin d'un fils de
[ __ ]
et tu es  le seul que j'ai
tu sais que tu n'as pas à m'appeler
pacificateur tu peux m'appeler chris juste
parce que tu es beau ne veut pas dire que
tu n'es pas une merde tu penses que je suis
beau oh mon dieu d'
accord
ça  le groupe de travail n'existe pas officiellement
tu veux faire ce travail
tu ne peux pas aboyer jamais
écouter je peux t'aider je vole avec des
armes au combat
[Musique]
tu n'as pas besoin de tirer sur les gens après elle
pour les tuer
[ __ ]  jour de match chiennes
ar  n'êtes-vous pas un peu
nonchalants à propos de tout cela,
insinuez-vous qu'il y a un mauvais moment et un
bon moment pour
rocker ouais
vous ne comprenez pas à quoi nous sommes
confrontés,
nous avons besoin de toutes les mains sur le pont
soit un acolyte oh mon
connard qu'est-ce qui ne va pas avec ton
oiseau un si bon beau garçon
mec nous sauvons le monde
c'est tout ce que nous avons toujours voulu
oh [ __ ] mec
[Applaudissements]
dis-moi ce que tu
sais comment tu aimes ça je  j'aime ça j'aime
beaucoup j'en ai rien à [ __ ] de tout ce que
tu as
hé
ne t'inquiète pas je ne donne rien à ce gars
euh peut-être que tu pourrais juste lui donner un
peu
hé douces joues peux-tu prendre ma commande
très vite sérieusement je n'ai pas chit les
joues de churu c'est le continent les joues douces c'est
ton cul non ce n'est pas c'est comme
appeler quelqu'un je ne sais pas les seins de sucre
totalement inappropriés les
jets sont bien trop gros pour être des seins de
sucre les ensembles de sucre sont comme des conseils plus petits
comme le
vôtre euh techniquement je pense que vous pourriez
avoir une mésange sucrée  c'est trop, mais d'une certaine manière, cela
vous semble également inapproprié